i said earlier you've been married for
40 years but but oddly i think i'm right
and saying
uh you never proposed samuel
do that mixed up things
i want to hear this story you never
propose
i don't remember well i don't remember
it actually i
i i do remember you
having some invitations in your hand and
saying this is when this is happening no
that's not what happened no
i said my grandfather is very ill
and he's going to die and he's very
concerned that we are not
married so we have to get married now
uh so that he can walk me down the aisle
that was his concern that
i was the last of his grandchildren um
not to be walked down the aisle in
marriage so so we have to get married so
now you have to ask him if you may marry
me
and then you have to ask me will i marry
you and you did
i did yes you did
okay okay it doesn't matter
but the wedding itself it was all
romantic i got down on one knee and did
the whole thing
no it was semantical but you know we did
i didn't say semantical i said romantic
to deal with later on today
you